alain samson bonsoir y est ici ce soir
votre nouvel album qui s'appelle le
désordre des choses c'est le quinzième
50 ans de carrière vous n'en revenait
toujours pas d'ailleurs vous dites je
suis une sorte de rescapés ça m'amuse
d'être encore là oui oui ça c'est dingue
ça c'est sûr que ça comme un mets sont
tous morts
alors on a le même âge mais oui ça 69
année érotique à
[Musique]
chaque fois que vous sortez un disque la
presse titre le retour du dandy vous ai
pas envie de débarquer sur un plateau
avec un rat sur l'épaule
on fait ce qu'on a et on s comment ce
congrès voilà finalement on accommode
alors c'est vrai que sur les plateaux
faisait plutôt discret le truc pire que
vous ayez fait je me souviens c'est
qu'une fois vous avez d'allier sans
mettre la main de bombay
on a beaucoup parlé ouais il va y avoir
de bonnes questions en suspens et chose
car je
connais dans la mise en abyme alors
alain chamfort est un dandy
oh
et l'emporter
dandy alors générique inc bien sûr c'est
génial non sous-estimer les kinks un
petit peu comme vous chauffe est
sous-estimé pas ce qu'on dit tout le
temps alain chamfort c'est manureva
entre autres c'est ça aussi je suis
d'accord des dizaines de il ya beaucoup
d'autres choses d'ailleurs comme à
chaque fois vous venez de subir votre
propre musique story il ya peu près
je ne sais pas
alors cette chanson passe en fait à la
fin de l'émission chaque semaine c'est
générique de fin que c'est ça
merci bonsoir c'était salut les terriens
jagger bon alors yassa elias âgé
[Musique]
baby loup
et à
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
pendant
vous
[Musique]
le soir
oh
moi quand tu es dans ce décès où
je bois chasse
juste histoire
put
pensez couleurs
chassez rétro
je sais les faits
je
c'est quand
[Musique]
tu es
ce chrétien c'est segré sucré 7 est ce
que nos secrets c'est ce grèce eu trait
sur mars
frey classés secrets sucre et un baiser
la quête dans le sang cette prime est
chaude les sens
t je perds à aiton
[Musique]
du ciel
bien forte quand on perd
[Musique]
v
les
les toits
ce faire
là
m
ce n'est
le trait
ce n'est que moi
voilà champion ne savais pas que magnol
un beagle
[Musique]
alors maintenant c'était le bateau
d'alain colas ah ouais ça ça c'est mieux
qu'à peine de 8,5 fleury michon sur
votre mélodies gainsbourg avait écrit à
dieu californien
[Musique]
voilà si vous plaisait pas du tout ça
vous plaise ou non c'est si on chantait
si bien
j'entendais parler de la mort d'alain
colas ou fait ce à quoi
basez le texte est quand même nettement
mieux et s'adapte mieux à la musique ça
donne une vraie chanson vous étiez
ensemble avec gainsbourg à los angeles
vous verriez ball s'est décollée non
mais je vais emmener là bas quand même
pour essayer de sortir un peu de ses
démons
l'attirance des sollicitations qu'il
avait sur paris sans arrêt mais ça va
changer rien donc il est arrivé avec des
trucs écrits sur des bouts de papier
mais c'est que ça n'a pas empêché de
dire beaucoup de bien de vous gainsbourg
ah oui oui je retrouvais sarsgaard et
une élégance sa gestuelle son regain
celle enregistrée à sion
contrôle bogard soir
je suis pas ya tous cru et à bel abbès
moi je dis j'ai des fanatiques je parle
ou faire un j'ai fait
en l2
12 qu'elle et lui ce gamin
il tombe toujours un
traître a su
ce
que ça casse le sarcasme
dernier à melun du tout je mets tout du
tout d'un des étudiants diocèse se
déconnecte faut pas quoi 169 un
garçon mais il me fait beaucoup de peine
[Applaudissements]
là ils étaient bien bourré 1 le mec à
qui vous avez travaillé dans tous
étaient jaloux de sa conseil du cran du
3d jeune coco qui jalousent bloc
l'engagement de façon pire il lui
donnait que 20 % de la lumière vint pour
son et musicien c'est vrai mario est
très jaloux de vous alors vous avez eu
des hauts et des bas mais vous revenez
toujours tel le phénix aujourd'hui avec
un album magnifique s'appelle le
désordre des choses vous dit malgré la
volonté de mettre de l'ordre je crois
que c'est quand même le désordre qui
gagne toujours c'est pas ça oui
et 7 ouest l'album c'est un peu c'est un
joli titre en plus pour l'album qui
prend en compte un petit peu lol
l'environnement dans lequel on se trouve
aussi nos mots d ordre personnel
existentielle en face et je sors un peu
de will album est résolument moins
romantique vous parlez moi d'amour vous
aborder des thèmes évidemment de
sociétés des thèmes existentiels vous
parlez de la déshumanisation parler
d'individualisme nous et cette phrase
terrible terrible les seuls qui s'en
sortent sont ceux qui ne font pas cas
les autres
ça va bien tu as des pressions
oui enfin je sais pas j'ai du bessat ont
donné ou c'était pas bien effectivement
il
ya quand même une part de vérité là
dedans bien c'est très juste c'est très
juste parce que tu as écouté exister tu
m'écoutes exister jeunes à tort dis moi
s'il te christophe est périmée existait
quelques chansons merveilleuses
[Musique]
existe et ça tombe dessus
comme un grain un soir d'automne
[Musique]
existé n'est pas un dû on arrive comme
un autre
[Musique]
y'avait personne
existé n'est pas un ça demande un camion
cru tellement parfois sames d'état
exister
quels sports de rue
sur cette fin des
parents exister explique désordre laissé
son nouvel album et vous serez donc au
trianon le 15 novembre
2018 le désordre des choses a été salué
par la critique
les inrocks qui me détestent mais qui
vous adore a dit un disque splendide aux
paroles génial qui confirme l'éternelle
jeunesse du chanteur pop frenchy et chic
bien ailleurs la regarder jouer soit
sans visa c'est chamfort ça tu changeras
plus il est comme il est tu cesses bon
alors on lit aussi sacre de l'élégance
mélodies sublimes veut définir parler de
culte
je sais pas on verra j'essaye de
simplement de faire ce que j'aime quoi
voilà c'est dans la joie dans la joie
dans la joie toujours
non mais il dit une phrase que j'aime
beaucoup ma manière d'être c'est de me
situer un peu en retrait oui j'ai ma
nature je suis comme ça et j'avais quoi
c'est pas de sources à mes jeux c'est
vrai que c'est pas ma meilleure place
n'est pas sur un plateau télé non aucun
moi je suis ravi de vous recevoir à
chaque fois
il dit je n'ai pas l'attitude ni le
discours d'un vainqueur quand ça ne
marchait pas je finissais par trouvé que
c'était presque normale
oui parce que j'ai jamais
essayer de travailler en fonction des
attentes qu en particulier alors que si
je les fais au début quand tu t'es chez
avec l'autre en soit les enseignants
chansons de les formater était qu'ils
étaient construites pour atteindre un
public voilà et ça j'ai fait pendant
quatre ans et va en donner jeu ça me
convenait plus quand j'étais échappé
vous avez bien fait en tous les cas
bravo parce que vous pourriez être sur
la tournée âge tendre oui c'est vrai 1
c'est assez touchant tout ça aussi je
trouve qu'il ya quelque chose pendant
devant daliot qui n'était pas du tout
dans ce registre départ se retrouve sur
ce soit sur cette tournée là il est
finalement elle a trouvé une espèce de
terre d'accueil enfin avec des gens qui
sont tous j'ai aucun mépris pour ça on
en parle souvent de cette tournée ici
bien sûr mais vous n'y êtes pas mais je
ne suis pas voilà ce qui est plutôt bien
alors j'ai pas une rock star non là on
va faire une interview rockstar d'accord
[Musique]
est-ce que vous avez déjà fait des
caprices bizarre dans notre loge avant
un concert non mais c'est peut-être ça
justement qui est bizarre jamais exigé
de la coke une put
voir la mer par là par la fenêtre alors
qu'on ait à montferrand alors tu te
baiser la fille
est ce que vous êtes déjà battu avec vos
musiciens
on a vite réglé le problème il son art
le tour bus et moi dans le jet privé
est ce que vous avez fait un piercing un
endroit extrêmement intime ne dit pas
cette tv
s'il vous du sexe est un endroit intime
pour vous
non
mais déjà dormi la veille de nuit non on
parle de rockstar mes enfants
je vous ai déjà pris de la coke dans les
toilettes avant de monter sur scène
pendant les toilettes
combien y aille
est ce que j'avais à 4 tout âge
mais pas trop tard moi je vais me faire
tatouer l'année prochaine va mettre ses
10 ans avec audrey a noté m parce que je
le sais déjà dit c'est pas la première
mais ce sera sûrement la dernière phrase
de serge gainsbourg je me fais d'une
fleur de lys et ou sur le q
est ce que j'ai déjà frappé une fan trop
entreprenante
non seulement quant à elle demandait
quoi même si ben voilà on y arrive
et pour être sûr de ne rien rater le in
a l'habitude abonnez vous y mettez un
peu de bleu